und wir wollen jetzt mit vitali
klitschko über die situation in
weißrussland sprechen er ist politiker
in der ukraine und ehemalige
box-weltmeister klitschko schön dass sie
sich die zeit genommen haben meine erste
frage was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn
sie die bilder der proteste sehen und
erinnert sie das an die proteste auf dem
majdan damals vor sechs jahren haben wir
genau das gleiche piste in ein ventil
gehabt aber damals in die beste
europäische band europäische zukunft
wegen assoziierungsabkommen will nicht
ruhig so unterscheiden weil ja alle
wollen
insofern ein teil von europäische
familie zu seinen europäischen werken
vom leben ohne europäische rechte ihn
noch keiner zu bringen
aber es betrifft jetzt im moment
weißrussland und gerechtigkeit was
betrieb volksabstimmung präsident war in
weißrussland und da wollte er sich wohl
rechte verletzt
deswegen das grundwasser folgen der die
ganze info bekommen wir nicht so viele
info und weißrussland aber draußen dem
höhe ganz wert info was haben wir eben
noch eine von weißrussland zeigt dass es
folgten recht mehr verletzt
das war die wichtigste grund jetzt im
moment die proteste das betrifft
eine demonstration in weiß fußball gehen
sie denn jetzt davon aus dass platin
wladimir putin sowie in der ukraine auch
in weißrussland eingreifen wird
ich habe keine zweifel in russland will
der große einfluss seien alle länder
ehemalige sowjet ehemalige
sowjetrepubliken immer einfluss haben
und ich schließe nicht aus
regierungshand wird auch involviert in
diese prozesse laufen wie weit
unterscheiden sich denn die proteste von
kiew zu denen die jetzt in minsk
stattfinden
die große unterschied wie was ist gleich
das umgeht was gehört an jeder der in
weißrussland genau das gleiche gefühl
nur ein show gehabt damals aber die
unterschied der unterschied
bildunterschrift volksabstimmung mehr in
weißrussland nicht so weh macht
präsentieren sie die ganze volk ist
nicht einverstanden mit
präsidentschaftwahl in der weißrussland
und die fühlen sich wie bekommen wir
info gedrückt und demokratische rechte
und freiheiten und haben sie eine
konkrete idee was deutschland
beziehungsweise die kanzlerin jetzt tun
kann um den menschen zu helfen die
menschenrechte das ist die wichtigste
wahl für eine gesellschaft die in
weißrussland bevölkerung ziel der gerne
levin stockwerken pressefreiheit und
menschenrechte zu haben was und wie viel
sich verletzten vitali klitschko vielen
vielen dank für das gespräch und die
einschätzungen besten dank
und wir schalten weiter zu bild vize
paul ronzheimer darf uns in linz ist
paul lorenz vitali klitschko sehr gut
und war es auch damals bei den protesten
dabei was ist denn der unterschied
zwischen den protesten auf dem majdan
und denen jetzt in minsk vitali
klitschko denn vitali klitschko war mit
anderen dort damals der anführer bei
diesen prozessen und er war der
oppositionschef für eine zeit lagen und
auf derjenige der hohe chancen hatte
damals ja nun komme ich nach zehn folgen
und das problem für die demonstration
ist ein bisschen dass es keine klare
anführerin ist eine ist nach litauen
geplant vor und schenkte andere sind
hier verstreut das heißt es spielt
glücklicherweise nicht klare
ansprechpartner denn sehr klare
ansprechpartner auf die internationale
gemeinschaft unabhängig davon gibt es
noch einen weiteren großen unterschieden
tier in der ukraine insgesamt ging es
auch sehr schnell darum was mit einer
pro-europäischen anwendung passiert ist
beim europäischer protest und auch ein
protest zum beispiel für eine nahezu
anbindung all diese stimmen sind
zumindest noch hier in belarus nicht
bewährt behörden und ist auch nichts von
einer erhöhung seiner art und weise
anderen russischen stimmungen zu tun
hier singen bringen ich habe auch nicht
dabei am anfang sondern erst dann als
gut sieben punkten bestätigt hat aber
insgesamt schwer vergleichbar beide und
trainer gewisser weise das gleiche denn
sie wollen beide einig kann verlost
werden und eine wahnsinns und hier ist
es verschenkt